comenzamos reporteros de france 24
gracias por estar con nosotros
el proyecto nord stream 2 nombre con el
que se conoce el gasoducto de mil 230
kilómetros que conectará con gas natural
a rusia con alemania y europa central y
del este y aún inconcluso pero casi
terminado está en pleno apogeo a pesar
de las críticas de la comunidad
internacional y las sanciones de eeuu
rusia y alemania- quieren completar este
gasoducto de 12 mil millones de dólares
lo antes posible sin embargo las ong
medioambientales europa
ucrania y la unión americana han ido a
la guerra contra este proyecto en el mar
báltico por cuestiones económicas pero
también geopolíticas aunque hace pocos
días anunciaron un acuerdo que frena la
larga disputa el siguiente reportaje es
de nuestros corresponsales en alemania
rusia y ucrania
[Música]
las nits una pequeña estación balnearia
alemana a orillas del mar báltico
podemos ir juntos a la primera fila de
tuberías no hay problema
y su alcalde hoy está feliz frank crack
por fin podrá deshacerse de los miles de
tubos que han estado apilados en su
puerto industrial durante los últimos
dos años
espero que esta zona de almacenamiento
pronto esté disponible para nuevos
proyectos estos tubos deberían haber
sido transportados a alta mar a medida
que avanzaba la producción pero
lamentablemente las obras se detuvieron
en 2019
[Música]
en alta mar a unos 150 kilómetros de
aquí se han reanudado las obras para
construir el gasoducto nord stream 2
se prevé que el gasoducto de mil 230
kilómetros duplicará la capacidad del
norte swing 1 uniendo a rusia
directamente con alemania
[Música]
no hay imágenes oficiales que muestren
los barcos rusos en una carrera
contrarreloj solo las hay de los buques
suizos que se han retirado del proyecto
ante las sanciones de eeuu
[Música]
por su parte franca que sigue convencido
de las ventajas del nuevo windows sin
embargo como el alcalde y principal
accionista del puerto de esas knicks
también está en el punto de mira de eeuu
en agosto de 2020 incluso recibió una
carta con amenazas firmadas por tres
senadores estadounidenses
[Música]
'destroyed' realmente escribieron
'destroyed' dicen que nos exponemos a
sanciones que amenazan la supervivencia
financiera del puerto esta es nuestra
política energética como alemanes y
europeos y los estadounidenses no tienen
por qué interferir en ellas
sanciones que alemania considera una
violación a su soberanía y que rusia ha
pasado por alto para reanudar las obras
pero como si todos sus socios europeos
se retiraron
[Música]
en moscú konstantín símonov dirige el
fondo nacional de seguridad energética
de rusia entre las empresas a las que
asesora se encuentra gazprom el gigante
ruso de gas propietario del nord windows
[Música]
tierra el primer problema era técnico
tenía gazprom la capacidad de colocar
los tubos por sí misma la barcaza rusa
fortuna era un buque para el tendido de
tuberías pero no estaba previsto que
trabajara a grandes profundidades en
cuanto al ser esquí este buque podía ser
adaptado para en diciembre de 2019 no
tenía los equipos de soldadura
necesarios ya que las sanciones
igualmente están dirigidas a las
compañías de seguros y certificación de
equipos también en ese caso fue
necesario actuar con astucia
a principios de 2021 en rusia se
registró una compañía de seguros
totalmente nueva en un tiempo récord con
un gran capital en mi opinión se creó
específicamente para asegurar el nord
stream 2 este gasoducto le permite a
rusia ahorrar mil 900 kilómetros lo que
reduce considerablemente los costos de
explotación pero también le permite
excluir a ucrania como país de tránsito
y esto no es tanto una cuestión política
como una cuestión de dinero
[Música]
ucrania y sus 33 mil kilómetros de
gasoductos en 2020 el país transportó 56
mil millones de metros cúbicos de gas
ruso a europa
[Música]
los ingresos 2 mil millones de dólares
en gastos de tránsito y una importante
pérdida si rusia modifica su ruta
más aún cuando ucrania está modernizando
su red y sus estaciones de compresión
gracias en particular a los créditos ya
los ingenieros alemanes
y esta estación de compresión es la
primera que renovamos no sólo la
renovamos sino que también instalamos
una nueva tecnología lo pueden ver aquí
detrás de mí con estas dos nuevas
unidades
michael dwelling trabaja en este
proyecto por encargo de una empresa
alemana el costo de la obra para el
operador ucraniano es de 80 millones de
euros otras 9 estaciones ucranianas
también esperan ser renovadas pero hasta
aquí llegaría todo si el nord windows
toma el relevo
no podemos invertir constantemente en
nuestro sistema y luego esperar a que
esté operativo sólo dos semanas mientras
el north stream está en mantenimiento no
tiene sentido económico así que sólo
podemos mantener nuestro sistema si
tenemos un contrato de tránsito a largo
plazo en el futuro
para ser más responsable de la red de
gasoductos ucranianos el norte windows
no tiene otro objetivo que aumentar la
influencia de rusia en europa chamanes
alemania apoya el nord stream 12 pero
muchos otros países están en contra del
north stream 2
así que gazprom está dividiendo europa
desde dentro sabemos que ese es su
objetivo porque gazprom no es sólo una
empresa comercial no son parte del juego
geopolítico
ucrania es ante todo un país que está en
guerra con rusia en el este el conflicto
armado con los separatistas apoyadas por
moscú se ha cobrado ya más de 14.000
vidas según cifras oficiales en la
capital kiev muchos de los gasoductos
como una última protección contra una
agresión rusa a mayor escala
una opinión que resuena incluso dentro
de las paredes de las trojas la compañía
de gas ucraniana aunque ésta está
familiarizada con los sucesivos
conflictos por el gas con su gran vecino
si el gas deja de transitar por ucrania
comentan las posibilidades de una guerra
total entre rusia y ucrania y de una
agresión a gran escala contra ucrania
por parte de rusia porque entonces rusia
no dudará en invadir más partes de
ucrania no sólo el este del país sino
también el norte y el centro no creo que
esto sea del interés de europa y
ciertamente no es del interés de ucrania
[Música]
en lumin se está lejos de estas
preocupaciones un socorrista en su
tiempo libre el alcalde de este pequeño
municipio de la antigua alemania del
este
recuerda bien los inicios de este tras
la caída del muro empezamos a pequeña
escala porque no sabíamos cómo hacerlo y
solo hicimos un pequeño hotel para
nosotros los alemanes del este era algo
completamente nuevo
pero actualmente el turismo no es lo que
hace prosperar alumni no muy lejos de la
orilla del mar la estación de llegada
del nord swing uno funciona desde 2012
la del norte 12 está lista desde 2019 el
alcalde espera impaciente que entre en
funcionamiento
y en el impuesto comercial del norte
uno representa un 30 35 por ciento de
los ingresos del municipio cuando esté
en pleno funcionamiento estos ingresos
se duplicaron en 1.5 millones de euros
al año con los que lo mm ya compró un
estadio y una guardería
pero el dinero no es el único argumento
para los habitantes de esta antigua zona
comunista
y aquí había muy pocos habitantes sin
ninguna industria
por eso los ingenieros soviéticos
eligieron este sitio
no son
matías leads fue el alcalde de lubmin
tras la caída del muro en la época
soviética la central nuclear construida
por los soviéticos hacía vivir al
municipio tras su cierre tuvo la idea de
llevar el gas ruso alumni queríamos
encontrar la manera de explorar el
potencial de este emplazamiento
industrial ya en los años 90 pensábamos
en cómo transportar el gas ruso a europa
occidental al igual que el ex alcalde
los locales que conocieron el comunismo
aprendieron ruso en la escuela
la propietaria de estos del restaurante
que antes fue profesora estuvo varias
veces en la unión soviética para ella
como para otros aquí los vínculos son
indelebles
y no conozco a nadie en nuestra región
que le tenga miedo a putin
aunque puede ser porque nuestras
relaciones con rusia a lo largo de estos
años siempre han sido positivas
así nos educaron para nosotros los
gustos son nuestros amigos centers
[Música]
en esta región con muchos vestigios del
pasado de los responsables políticos son
firmes partidarios del 'no' espn2 el
ministro regional visita a un búnker
soviético convertido en museo afirma que
el gasoducto es vital para la transición
energética de alemania país que abandonó
la energía nuclear y que ahora planea
eliminar el uso del carbón
incluso durante las horas más oscuras de
la guerra fría rusia nunca le cortó el
suministro de gas a alemania occidental
la dependencia económica era simplemente
demasiado importante en ambas
direcciones alemania y europa en general
quieren darle un giro a la energía y
esta es la forma más eficiente de ser
independientes pero hasta entonces
necesitamos un poco más de gas
pero en un país en el que la emergencia
climática está en el centro del debate
la resistencia al norte windows siempre
está presente
wagner este gasoducto se está
convirtiendo en un desastre para los
derechos humanos y la democracia es un
proyecto que no necesitamos para nuestra
política energética y al que debemos
oponernos
el shuar en la capital de la región los
jóvenes del movimiento frailes perfil
sur viernes para el futuro en español el
movimiento a greta thunberg se
manifiestan desde la reanudación de las
obras para exigir que no continúe
en el gas no es una buena solución es
tan perjudicial como el carbón y se
subestima su impacto negativo en el
clima además invertimos ahora en el gas
y no en el desarrollo de las energías
renovables ralentizar hemos nuestro
cambio energético y no alcanzaremos
nuestros objetivos climáticos su
esperanza que las acciones legales de
las ong medioambientales contra él no es
fin dos tengan éxito pero también que
haya un cambio político en septiembre
louis votará por primera vez en las
elecciones legislativas votará por el
partido verde que promete detener el
proyecto realmente espero que los verdes
pongan esto como condición para
participar en un gobierno y tal como en
las cosas tendrán los medios para
imponer el fin de este proyecto durante
las negociaciones es este la razón por
la que moscú quiere
las obras lo antes posible en berlín
tenemos una cita con el embajador ruso
en alemania
[Música]
sergei net saif que trabajó en la
embajada de la unión soviética en
alemania oriental nos recibe en la sala
donde angela merkel y vladimir putin se
reunieron por primera vez en 2005 y
afirma que nada se interpondrá en el
camino de dos de nuestros amigos
estadounidenses son muy creativos con
las sanciones que son ilegítimas
pero nosotros estamos comprometidos con
este proyecto y lo construiremos hasta
el final de un tiempo nuestros
trabajadores trabajan al ritmo que la
tecnología y las condiciones
meteorológicas lo permiten
y sin preocuparse de las coyunturas
políticas o va porque este no es un
proyecto político sino económicos están
los socios comerciales son tan en
pero el destino del nor swing 2 depende
en gran medida de la situación política
con un 20% de intención de voto el
partido verde es el enemigo número uno
del gasoducto en alemania de visita en
ucrania para marcar su ruptura con la
línea pro rusa del actual gobierno el co
líder del partido verde del que podría
salir la futura canciller alemana envía
un mensaje claro
y estoy en contra del norte string 2
completamente en contra creo que fue un
error desde el principio y que no
debería terminarse y que nuestro
gobierno se equivoca en tomar esta
dirección
pero robert huff está de acuerdo con que
una vez terminada la obra será más
difícil oponerse
desde el punto de vista legal es
complicado es una inversión privada si
la inversión privada se completa las
empresas privadas son libres de disponer
de ella y llevarán el caso a los
tribunales por lo tanto lo más
importante es impedir que se terminen
las obras no está es 30 no debe ser
completado
en el mar lejos de la mirada del público
la construcción está en plena marcha una
vez completada verá el norisring 2 la
siguiente batalla la de la explotación
de su gas todos los escenarios son
posibles porque se diga lo que se diga
este es ante todo un asunto geopolítico
[Música]
gracias por compartir con nosotros en
reporteros de france 24 recuerde que
puede ingresar a nuestra página web para
ver esta emisión y las anteriores hasta
la próxima semana
[Música]